since the end of World War two the
world's been built on an idea called
deterrence it says that if you attack me
you my allies I'll retaliate so we're
both better off not fighting it's why
the Cold War stayed cold and the skies
over Cuba American reconnaissance planes
wait back and forth weather hasn't been
a war between major powers in 70 years
it's kept the world stable it's the
reason we still have nuclear weapons and
the reason we haven't used them since
1945 but deterrence is changing new
forms of warfare are blurring the old
lines and rewriting the old rules so I
went to ask Secretary of Defense ash
Carter what this means for the world and
for the u.s. he said the stakes are high
and that the military's challenge will
be to establish new norms of deterrence
to convince America's adversaries that
the old rules still hold
it has the word terror inside it right
deterrence that's what it's about is you
scare somebody away from doing something
you don't want them to do by making them
fear the consequences to do that they
must know what the consequences are and
you're right it needs to be understood
there needs to be some sort of normality
to the idea that this threat will be
offered and it should deter and as we
get into new domains like cyber and
space and we try to situate old and very
solid ideas like deterrence in those new
domains it requires some thought the old
rules of deterrence set hard clear lines
for what would trigger a military
retaliation and those lines usually fall
across borders but no one knows how or
where to draw that sort of line when it
comes to things like cyber attacks in
the physical world it's easy to tell
when you're under attack by a foreign
military but not so online in 2013 for
example hackers based in Iran access the
control system for a small dam in New
York State but it took months for US
investigators to accuse the Iranian
government to being behind it the
hackers didn't cause any physical damage
but they could have and it raised
questions which are still unanswered
about when a hack becomes like a
military tack and when and how the US is
obligated to respond attack us in
cyberspace it's an attack and I'm very
straightforward an attack is an attack
and if you attack we won't necessarily
respond in space or respond in cyber we
may respond in some other way but we
will respond and you need to understand
that that if you're attacking American
interests there will be a response but
it's important to communicate that fact
that you're prepared for it we know
exactly what we're going to do and you
will regret your the consequences of
your act and you should be fearful of
those consequences and then not do it
and thus not do in the first place the
threat isn't just that new tools of
warfare like cyber attacks like
countries get away with things they
normally couldn't in regular war we have
what are called norms of proportionality
you bomb me I bomb you back but tools
like cyber are so new there are no norms
yet no one knows what sort of response
to expect and Carter says this can be
dangerous proportionality does mean if
you do something I'm going to do
something back to you but I'm not
necessarily going to do something that's
out of proportion and that makes it
necessary for you then to do more and
more and more that's called escalation
obviously nobody wants that the u.s. he
says has to have responses strong enough
to make any adversary stand down but not
so strong that it could make the other
country feel obligated to respond which
is how things could spiral out of
control so whatever we think about
deterrence responses we craft them in
such a way that they are not by
themselves intentionally or
unintentionally escalatory we always
retain the capability to escalate still
further that's part of deterring the
next move but it's not our intention
general to escalate something it's just
to stop it from ever occurring in the
first place and if it does occur to
punish it quickly which makes the
opponent say okay I realize my mistake I
stand down from my objectives and then
it's the end of it but it's not just
cyber war Russia is developing new
postmodern techniques known as hybrid
war Special Forces dressed up as
vigilantes attacks meant to create chaos
more than seized territory propaganda
and misinformation meant to spark panic
or even popular unrest the deterrence
works uncertainty who's doing what what
actions will spark retaliation but
hybrid war is about creating uncertainty
it makes it harder to determine who's
doing what and blurs the lines between
what is and isn't war and like with
cyber war the rules of hybrid war are
still unclear a Carter says the way to
deal with this is by keeping lines of
communication open so both sides control
any misunderstanding or escalation
before it gets out of control
it's very important to keep dialogue
even with potential enemies so that it
is understood where you stand what your
interests are and what you're prepared
to defend to do to defend them and
that's why I believe among many other
things very strongly in
military-to-military dialogue and
dialogue between me and my counterparts
even in countries where we have a
difficult time you can't stop a conflict
that your enemy deliberately provokes
but you can try to prevent ones that
they blunder into by underestimate you
know one of the ways you do that is by
signalling clearly to have a dialogue
are you satisfied with the level of
military-to-military communication with
Russia and China no I'd like to see more
in general but it takes two to tango and
so it's not just the amount it's the
character of the dialogue and the
willingness of those parties to have a
dialogue that we have the kind that we
would regard as as fruitful and that's
not everything that should be
in the last year of the Obama
administration Carter has been arguing
that the American military needs to
prepare for a new era of great power
competition primarily with Russia and
China and that means an era where
deterrence is even more important and
that deterrence ultimately is backed up
by nuclear weapons my bedrock of this
department here of Arc is our commitment
to nuclear security and also to
deterrence and our nuclear arsenal now
it's not in the headlines every day and
thank goodness for that but it's in the
back of my mind every day the US has
about 70 100 nuclear weapons of which
about 1500 are deployed and Russia has
about the same combined that's 90
percent of all nuclear weapons and they
exist never to be used just to deter
other nuclear states but there's a
strange logic to this to make sure we
never have to use them we need to
credibly threaten to use weapons that
would kill millions and send the world
into nuclear winter well to ask you
about that deterrence there's a story
that I love from when Dick Cheney had
your job of 1989 and he was getting a
briefing on US nuclear war plans and
there was a slide that came up for
retaliatory strike plans for Moscow one
of the things it showed was I think it
was something like 70 strikes on one
radar facility in sub suburb of Moscow
and he turned to his aides and he said
what the hell is this why are we doing
this kind of thing and the reason I
bring that up is I think that's the
reaction a lot of people have when they
are confronted with the logic of nuclear
deterrence and they see its ends I'm
sure in your years of working on nuclear
weapons that's a reaction you must hear
I do I hear it all the time and you know
and you never get quite used to how
terrible such a situation would be but
until someone has an alternative to
deterrence as dealing with someone who
might use nuclear weapons against you
and we haven't found in all those years
since the Manhattan Project any
effective defense
against nuclear weapons so until those
are found the only defense we have is
the threat of retaliation as the lines
of deterrence blur what does that mean
for nuclear weapons the u.s. plans to
spend 1 trillion dollars on modernizing
its nuclear weapons and Russia's making
upgrades as well Carter says this is
about maintaining the status quo a
balance between the nuclear powers that
keeps them away from conflict but he
acknowledges this carries some rizal do
you ever want to use it of course not
that's the whole purpose is never to use
it and thank goodness in all these
decades since 1945 I never a nuclear
weapon has not been used in anger since
then that's a remarkable achievement but
it's one I I don't take for granted but
with the growing uncertainty about what
does and doesn't trigger retaliation and
about what kind of retaliation to expect
I asked Carter whether he worried that
an unintended escalation to war could
happen and he said the answer was for
the US military to replace that
uncertainty with as much certainty as it
could bring it's we have awesome power
in our military we're not eager to use
it and we hope it causes others not to
do provocative things but if they do I
don't have any doubt that we will
prevail we certainly think through every
scenario that is possible to make sure
that we have plans that are provide for
the most sensible thing we could do at
the time with the capabilities we had
that's what that's what we're here for
that's a world where stability and peace
come from making everyone certain about
exactly when and how the US will use
military force but there's no such thing
as perfect certainty especially when the
technology and norms of war are changing
so quickly the Americans challenge will
be to constantly create new norms to
clarify new lines of deterrence to keep
pace with those changes